[Applaudissements]
en sortant de l'école nous avons
rencontré un grand bateau à voile qui
nous nous tenons un grand chemin de fer
qui nous a bien mangé oxala veut vous
arrivez pour la grande finale de poésie
c'est ça souvenez-vous l'autre jour
casimir a battu le sud du snob et le
facteur un match passionnant et
aujourd'hui eh bien je rencontre casimir
en finale
soyez voir qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est-ce
qui est gelée au regard des abats mai
mais il y en a partout surtout les
arbres de l'hylozoïsme voter casimir
vous aurez un bonbon c'est scandaleux
cette fin il faut reconnaître qu'il
exhale faire acheter les membres du jury
b a rien de plus malhonnêtes on devrait
les limites non il est tellement drôle
quand ils disent en poème qui aurait pu
grande finale de poésie que tu as raison
mais on va lui donner une bonne leçon
bien sûr il affirmé c'est fermé
julie oui s'il te plaît qui veuille bien
ouvrir le kiosque
peu avant lui parce que sabrina est pas
encore là et puis y'a rien n'urge corse
ici c'est très urgent tu veux une glace
aux enfants non je veux des bonbons des
boubous casimir t'as jamais mais bon moi
aussi j'aime les bonbons à j'adore mes
bonbons j'en raffole des bonbons tva ou
deux noms j'en veux un grand sage un cru
moins est alors alors
casimir tu n'aurais pas entendu parler
de quelqu'un qui a proposé des bonbons
aux enfants qu'ils voteraient pour un
certain comment déjà ah oui c'est ça
casimir des bonbons ah non non je ne
fais pas nous annoncer ça vient avec moi
casimir vient avec moi regarde et de
quelqu'un qui a posé des affiches un
petit peu partout non non non non
toujours rien il faisait mire
tu es un menteur tu as tricheurs qui en
plus qu'un petit peu idiot regarde en
bas des affiches les signes et de
tonneaux casimir e franches
j'ai honte je suis très heureux tu peux
tu je joue même caché qu à gagner
françois écoute résigne à casimir on
oublie tout ça julie s'il te plaît tu va
retirer les affiches
esneu casimir on va se mesurer loyal non
c'est entendu c'est promis à la loyale
vous êtes prêts en effet fallu les infos
que la grande finale du concours de
poésie va commencer ça va être terrible
premiers finalistes trois fois le
casimir tu prends mon vélo
allez merci bonne chance à bercy déjanté
aller j'y vais en sortant de l'école de
jacques prévert
en sortant de l'école nous avons
rencontré un grand chemin de fer qui
nous emmener tout autour de la terre
dans un wagon doré tout autour de la
terre nous avons rencontré l'anr qui se
promenait avec tous ces coquillages ces
îles parfumé et puis c'est beau naufrage
et ses saumons fumés au dessus de la mer
nous avons rencontré la lune et les
étoiles sur un bateau à voile
partant pour le japon il est trois
mousquetaires et cinq doigts de la main
tournant la manivelle d'un petit sous
marin plongeante au fond des mers pour
pêcher d orsay
revenant sur la terre nous avons
rencontré sur la voie du chemin de fer
une maison typhus et fuyez tout autour
de la terre fuyait tout autour de la mer
fuyaient devant libérer et voulait
l'attraper mais nous sur notre chemin de
fer on s'est mis à rouler rouler
derrière l'hiver et on l'a écrasée et la
maison s'est arrêté et le traitons nous
a salués
c'était lui le garde barrière et il nous
a bien remercié alors toutes les fleurs
de toute la terre soudain se sont mis à
pousser pousser à tort et à travers sur
la voie du chemin de fer qui ne voulait
plus avancé de peur de les abîmer
alors on est revenu à pied à pied
tout autour de la terre à pied tout
autour de la leyre tout autour du soleil
de la lune et des étoiles à pied à
cheval en voiture est d'accord
merci dd deuxième finaliste casini
désuni et intimidant merci bonne chance
qu est une hérésie alors de nouveaux
arrivés une moto dans une basse-cour
coin coin coin coin coin coin coin coin
coin coin coin coin coin quoi top 4 tab
à 3 pts 4 4 4 4
kodak a peut-être quatre cartes
quelque 44 mais à quoi joue pas non plus
été soumis d'appoint merveilleux
proclamation des résultats
france soir est nommé le meilleur 10
heures de poèmes de l'île aux enfants
merci merci merci
casimir est nommé le meilleur poète des
l'île aux enfants
bravo n'y a qu'à se contenter soir bon
avec moi deux meilleurs voilà il n'y a
pas beaucoup de tâches aussi un peu
juste merci
[Applaudissements]